while Washington works on a solution the
outbreak continues to spread and disrupt
daily daily life overnight Apple said it
will close all of his retail stores in
the United States and around the world
outside of China until March 27th the
company had recently opened its doors in
China that was shuttered because of the
outbreak there
the nationwide closure is the first
among major US retailers meanwhile
much-needed coronavirus testing is
underway in one of the hardest hit
communities in the US Michael George is
in New Rochelle New York with that and
more of what people around the nation
are dealing with Michael good morning
good morning Michelle this weekend
brings little relief to people directly
impacted by the corona virus pandemic in
their everyday lives with schools
closing the stock market tanking and
anxiety about staying healthy as experts
warn this will likely get worse before
it gets better
across the country shoppers emptied
grocery store shelves stocking up on
everything from toilet paper to
non-perishable goods
social distancing has become the new
normal
millions of Americans are staying home
as schools have closed in at least 14
states major sporting events are either
canceled or postponed the 124th running
of the Boston Marathon next week has
been postponed until September 17 states
have opened up drive-through testing
sites for coronavirus including here in
New Rochelle New York which has one of
the largest clusters of coronavirus with
more than 120 people affected they can
test two hundred people a day my
husband's not feeling well
he's got throat symptoms he's you know
80 and tired and he works in the city
the testing is not where it needs to be
bright the main way to slow the spread
we know from all the other countries is
to do the testing isolate the positives
healthcare officials say testing delays
have made it hard to contain the virus
private sector labs including Ross
Cleveland Clinic and quest Diagnostics
have developed their own tests and have
now partnered with the Trump
administration Matthew beniker of the
Mayo Clinic headed the team that worked
around the clock to come up with a test
kit in just three weeks we realized that
the public health infrastructure wasn't
going to be able to accommodate all the
testing that was going to be needed and
that clinical laboratories would need to
step up and participate but hospitals
across the country are bracing for a
surge in patients while emergency rooms
are already overwhelmed with people
worried they have the virus we are
probably at the tip of the iceberg at
this point in terms of what we are going
to be seeing in emergency rooms over the
next few weeks and medical experts also
worry if we continue to see a dramatic
rise in cases it could lead to a
shortage of hospital beds and equipment
like ventilators and in a worst case
scenario lead to rationed care Dana
Michael George thank you